over the past few months we've been
reporting on the new habit of Democrats
it's called ducking debates and given
the performances of those who do show up
it's not hard to see why take last
night's debate in Ohio between
Republican J.D Vance and Democrat faux
Congressman populist Tim Ryan claims to
be of course a man of the people but he
spent an entire career in public office
making their lives worse instead of
owning up to it he lies
I've been a natural gas proponent since
I've been in Congress Tim Ryan just told
a big FIB he said he supported Ohio's
natural gas industry and he's always
done so and yet Tim Ryan when he ran for
president was it two years ago you
supported Banning fracking both on
public lands and generally speaking
Bingo Ryan might like gas but that's
only because he usually sounds like a
gas bag and he hasn't just sold out his
constituents over High Energy prices he
said idly by while their jobs have been
shipped overseas timron represents a
congressional district that has lost 50
000 jobs just in his time in office I'd
like Tim Ryan to lecture me on my
business background a little bit less
and maybe explain why the guy who's the
biggest fighter of China had his own
congressional district lose tens of
thousands of good manufacturing jobs to
China just in your time
can I can I Tim Ryan needed to pull on
another pull up at that point I mean
that's how you do it though but that
wasn't just the most effective takedown
of the night there were many more at one
point Tim Ryan thought they had Vance
over the ropes over one issue the
Democrats put above all others of course
I'm talking about abortion now after
claiming that Vance wouldn't support
abortion in the case of the rape of a
young girl which is a lie he refused to
explain the background behind the tragic
story he used enter Vance
why was a 10 year old girl raped in our
community raped in our state in the
first place the thing the media and
Congress and Ryan they talk about this
all the time the thing they never
mentioned is that poor girl was raped by
an illegal alien you voted so many times
against border wall funding so many
times for amnesty Tim if you had done
your job she would have never been raped
in the first place do your job on border
security Don't lecture me about opinions
I don't actually have oh my God Tim's
like can I buy a vowel it's not just
enough though to point out the lies you
know all Republicans need to explain why
it is the Democrats who are excusing
policies that allow all this evil to
occur in our communities the time for
defensive candidates it's over
joining me now JD Vance GOP Senate
candidate in Ohio JD I I didn't get to
watch this live I had to watch it online
but it seemed like you were actually
having fun up there were you just acting
or were you actually you seemed to be
enjoying it and I certainly enjoyed it
it was awesome
yeah I was definitely having fun Laura
thank you for having me I mean you know
I've listened for four months of this
guy until lies about my own record tell
lies about his record and I just really
thought it was a great opportunity to
actually correct uh that record and tell
the truth about what a complete fraud
this guy is I mean again 100 voting work
with Joe Biden Nancy Pelosi pretends
he's a sensible moderate it just doesn't
hold up to scrutiny so I definitely
relish the opportunity to get in the
ring with him a little bit and actually
uh shake things up yeah he seemed at
several points during the
um during the debate like he had to like
pass a kidney stone or something he
looked very uncomfortable and he had an
interesting takeaway though from the
debate watch this
and uh by all accounts we won the debate
and uh you know we've got a lot of you
know people wanting to help and support
the campaign now Mitch McConnell gave
him 40 million bucks Peter Thiel gave
him 15. uh you know we're out here
schlogging it's David versus Goliath but
I think we got a really really good shot
to win this thing
y i I am trying to figure this out he's
trying to paint himself as an outsider
in the race is that what he just said
yeah that's his whole stick Laura of
course he just tells Whopper after
Whopper uh he doesn't tell you of course
that the national Democratic party has
ported tens of millions of dollars uh
into this race that they've consistently
tried to Define this guy in a way where
he runs away from his record and again
pretends that he's a moderate or even a
magnet conservative if you watch this
guy's TV commercials Laura you would
think that he was a right-wing
Republican because he knows his record
of achievement is non-existent and this
is one of the arguments I tried to
hammer home yesterday Laura at the end
of the day the substantive disagreements
between me and Tim are less significant
than the fact that he's been in Congress
for 20 years and he's gotten nothing
significant accomplished for his
congressional district he is the poster
boy of a failed establishment Elite that
tries to fail upward get promotions for
having failed with their basic job I
don't think those of us in Ohio were
going to fall for it no I don't either
and again uh he really showed
Republicans how to do this JD and
valuable service thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else